bah les lancers était symbolique le sous
texte encore plus fort l'ère des
conservateurs de stephen harper et leur
approche militariste et terminer le
canada et sa réputation humaniste dans
le monde est de retour
la première participation internationale
du nouveau gouvernement canadien a lieu
quelques mois plus tard à paris lors du
sommet sur le climat
on essaie de te résoudre les grands
enjeux pour qu'on puisse avoir et je
pense qu'on va avoir un accord ambitieux
la ministre de l'environnement catherine
mec qui n'a fait sensation elle joue un
rôle central dans l'adoption de l'accord
sur le climat le canada promet beaucoup
mais s'engage peu une des premières
promesses électorales réalisé sera
l'accueil de 25 mille réfugiés syriens
et le retrait des cf 18 canadiens des
zones de frappes aériennes
le nombre de soldats est par ailleurs
augmenté de quelques centaines dans les
pays limitrophes de la série
le gouvernement trudeau a fait très peu
pour changer la vocation militaire
canadien à l'étranger
la mission de 250 militaires et de huit
hélicoptères au mali aura duré un an
elle se termine ces jours ci les nations
unies avaient demandé au canada de
prolonger sa participation à cette
mission de casques bleus demande rejetée
par ailleurs l'émission de plus de 600
soldats en ukraine et en lettonie dans
le cadre de l'otan sont prolonger au
moins jusqu'en 2022 l'aide canadienne au
développement en particulier en afrique
a baissé de près de 10% au début du
mandat trudeau la contribution actuelle
du gouvernement à ce chapitre est plus
faible que celle de tous ses
prédécesseurs
elle sera rétablie au cours des
prochaines années avec un financement
bonifiés
sur le plan de l'image à l'étranger les
canadiens retiendront le voyage coûteux
et désastreux de justin trudeau et de sa
famille en aide non seulement le
déroulement de cette visite sera marquée
par plusieurs cafouillages
mais il n'a rapporté aucun dividende
malgré une réunion de dernière minute
avec le premier ministre indien
les relations du canada avec le monde
arabe se sont aussi détériorée avec les
palestiniens et certains des pays du
proche orient mais surtout avec l'arabie
saoudite
les déclarations de la ministre des
affaires étrangères sur le droit des
femmes soutenues par celles du premier
ministre ont semble-t-il créer un
refroidissement historique avec le
régime saoudien
les discussions avec l'arabie saoudite
continue la première année du mandat a
aussi été marquée par un réchauffement
des relations avec le voisin américain
un réchauffement de courte durée avec
l'arrivée d'un nouveau locataire à la
maison blanche malgré les tensions et
quelques montées de pression notable
entre les deux hommes la ministre
christian fruits l'inde a réussi à
négocier un nouvel accord de
libre-échange jugé tout à fait
convenable d'autres accords
internationaux de commerce sont aussi
conclu avec l'union européenne et les
pays du pacifique
l'aboutissement de négociations amorcées
à l'époque de stephen harper se sont
sans doute les relations avec la chine
qui ont le plus souffert au cours des
dernières années
l'arrestation de la patronne huawei
suivie de celle de deux canadiens en sol
chinois a mené à un affrontement
commercial qui mettra du temps à se
régler
pour l'instant le legs de justin trudeau
sur la scène internationale demeure
imprécis silva desjardins radio canada
montréal